- Hey there, "Two Cents" viewer.
Before we get started,
just a little bit of legal
housekeeping. (clearing throat)
By watching this video, you
are agreeing to the following.
You shall not copy, transcribe,
or publicly display this episode
(except at an awards show).
You may not disparage
"Two Cents" or its hosts
in any capacity.
And that includes comments
about Philip's hair,
or lack thereof.
You must subscribe to
the "Two Cents" channel
and click the notifications bell
and become a patron on our Patreon page.
Link in the description.
You will tell at least five friends
that "Two Cents" is your
favorite show of all time,
and if they don't watch it,
you won't be their friend anymore.
By continuing to play this video,
you are agreeing to be bound
by the aforementioned terms
and conditions of this end
user license agreement.
For those of you who are still here,
thank you for being such
disturbingly loyal fans,
but alas, this is not
remotely enforceable.
(button beeping)
This, however, is.
(lively music)
- As a CFP, I would ordinarily
never advise someone
to sign a contract that they haven't read.
But when it comes to EULAs,
or End User License Agreements,
we don't really have a choice.
- If you wanna participate
in modern society,
you probably have to click, "I agree,"
at least a dozen times a month.
And the idea that any of us would
or could actually read all the terms
and conditions is ludicrous.
iTunes' agreement is
longer than "Macbeth,"
just to buy a $2 song.
- And even though we all
check the box that says,
"I have read and understand these terms,"
most people would need an
extended session with a lawyer
to really know what they're agreeing to.
One study estimated that
the average American
would have to devote an entire month
to properly understand all
the terms and conditions
they agree to each year.
- If you need any more evidence
that people don't read these things,
one games retailer snuck a clause
into their terms and conditions,
giving the company "a
non-transferrable option to claim
for now and forevermore,
your immortal soul."
Over 7,000 people clicked, "Agree."
22,000 people committed to 1,000 hours
of community service in
exchange for free wifi.
And when a software maker promised $1,000
to the first person who noticed the offer
in the fine print of their EULA,
it took four months for
someone to claim it.
- Most of us have just accepted all this
as an annoying fact of modern life,
a technocratic oddity of the internet age.
But EULAs are just the
latest weapon in a battle
that's been going on for 100 years,
a battle against ownership rights.
- In 1904, the publisher Bobbs-Merrill
printed a small disclaimer
inside each copy
of the novel, "The Castaway."
It read, "The price of this
book is one dollar net.
No dealer is licensed to
sell it at a less price,
and a sale at a less price will be treated
as an infringement of the copyright."
- [Philip] Like most publishers,
Bobbs-Merrill saw used bookstores
as a threat to their business.
In a perfect world, everyone
who wanted to read their book
would have to buy their own
brand new copy at full price,
and they thought they could
force people to do that
by invoking copyright law.
- It didn't work.
The courts struck down their lawsuit
because they saw it as an
attempt to attach servitude
to personal property.
Servitude refers to conditions
or obligations that are
tied to a sold property.
It's most common in real estate,
like mandating what kind
of structures can be built
on a piece of land.
But it's not allowed when it
comes to personal property.
You can't sell someone a hammer
and then tell them what
they can build with it.
The new owner can use their property
how and when they want.
- These rights of ownership were codified
in the Copyright Act of 1909.
It created protections for the owners
of intellectual property
like authors and publishers,
but it also carved out some rights
for the buyers of individual copies.
According to the Act, if you buy a book,
you can't make duplicates and sell them.
You can't charge audiences
to hear a public reading
or sell your own sequel.
You can, however, resell
the book if you want to,
or lend it to a friend,
or give it as a gift.
- Over the next hundred years,
those rights of ownership
have been relentlessly
targeted by IP owners.
Record companies tried to
shut down used music shops.
Movie studios tried to
criminalize the VCR,
and video game developers
tried to stop the sale
of used games.
While digital technology has
created some real threats
of illegal duplication and piracy,
most of these efforts are about control,
trying to control how people use a product
after they've bought it.
- Time and again, the
courts sided with consumers,
ruling that unless people were making
and distributing illegal copies,
they were free to do whatever they wanted
with their individual copies.
But with the digital revolution,
IP holders found a way around the law:
ask consumers to voluntarily sign away
their rights to ownership as
a condition of the purchase,
the End User License Agreement.
- Even though e-sellers use language like,
"Buy now," and "Own it in 4K,"
if you actually read the terms,
you'll find that you don't
actually own the thing you buy,
you're just getting a license
or permission to use it
in certain limited ways.
Most EULAs don't allow you to
lend or gift your purchases
and dictate what devices
you can use them on.
Some prohibit any kind of disparagement,
which could even mean a negative review.
And many reserve the right
to revoke your license at
any time without a refund.
- Besides the loss of ownership rights,
the shift from buying to licensing
has other economic downsides.
Artists make much less from streaming
than they did from physical media
and lack that tactile
connection to their fans.
The death of used media shops may mean
that lower income audiences
will have fewer ways
to discover music and movies,
which, in the long run,
is bad for the industry.
And if switching from
one platform to another,
like say PlayStation to Xbox
means you'll lose your entire library,
customers are so locked in
that there's little motivation
for companies to innovate or compete.
- Nevertheless, EULAs have become
so lucrative for businesses
that they're looking to
expand them beyond IP
into more tangible
purchases like vehicles,
appliances, and electronics.
Anything with a processor can
be loaded with simple software
that allows the seller
to control its functioning after purchase.
Coffee makers can be programmed
to only brew certain brands of coffee.
Cars and tractors can be encrypted
to prohibit even simple repairs
unless at an official dealership.
And printers can be remotely
bricked by the company
if you're late paying the
toner subscription fee.
- Ordinarily, this kind of
servitude would be illegal.
The law clearly gives
buyers the right to alter,
repair, or resell whatever they own.
But though you may own the coffee maker,
you don't own the
software installed on it,
you're just licensing it,
which means any attempt to subvert
or bypass it is a breach of contract.
If things keep going this way,
someday, you could get sued
just for loaning your
lawnmower to a neighbor.
- But there is a backlash gaining momentum
known as the Right to Repair movement.
More than half the states are considering
or have passed bills
that prohibit companies
from inserting these kinds
of digital restrictions
into physical products.
And unlike almost every
other issue in America,
this one is uniting people from both sides
of the political spectrum.
Turns out that the vast
majority of Americans believe
that you should be able
to do what you want
with the stuff you buy.
- Maybe with a little political action,
we can stop a dystopian future
where we're all subscribers
rather than owners.
But until then, EULAs are
enforceable contracts.
Even though consumers
have no way around them,
many courts have affirmed
that it is indeed possible
to waive your hundred year
old rights of ownership
just by clicking on a box.
- And unless you're willing to opt out
of all popular culture,
that's what you'll have to do.
But don't kid yourself,
you're not buying anything.
They're just letting
you use it for a while.
- [Both] And that's our two cents.
- Before you go, we wanna
tell you about a new show
on PBS Origins, "A People's
History of Native America,"
hosted by comedian and
actor Tai' Leclaire,
it's a miniseries that explores
the current social climate
in Native America,
diving deep into the
history of tribal nations
and the external factors
that have shaped
contemporary circumstances.
There's a link in the description.
We hope you enjoy.
(lively music)